this morning I was cruising through my
neighborhood wearing my favorite hat
carrying a big old bag of balls oh no
wait I was wearing my basketball gear
yeah that's right and going for a
training session with the homies Who am
I kidding I don't have any boss four
homies or a big old bag of bolts I was
actually in my basement parking locked
with three balls I got from down the
road in the beginning there was just
three normal sounding basketballs my
mission here was to turn we find three
notes
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll work de Bie after turn cheating
the basketballs I sanitized my hands
because coronavirus this check is just
too good to not recreate with all the
sounds around me welcome to this week
seeing sounds let's do this now this is
a story all about how my life got
flipped turned upside down I'd like to
take a minute come right this way and
tell you how I got to this town called
la
[Music]
okay kaneki katom born and raised and
the ocean is where I spend most of my
days so hard and got no money for
assuming that I never paid attention
inside of us then a couple of years sure
absolutely
I was making trouble and I took to my
camera thought this is the way if you
want to take it serious you gotta get to
LA I worked a little harder time and a
bunch of red Awards the medication then
one day got the call he said this is
okay so I got myself a ticket your
home's to LA thank you so much for
watching this week seeing science Will
Smith I hope that you get to see this
and that you like it I'm wearing your
ballet shirt please remember to give me
suggestions for new tracks that I should
recreate in the comments below and
subscribe to my channel it's just a
simple click of a button as well as turn
your notifications bow on other than
that
don't forget your awesome brew and I'll
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
kaneki katom born and raised and the
ocean is where I spend most of my days
so I don't got no money forest